- But I'm very, very
excited, and so is Rubin,
who loves superhero stuff more
than me and all this stuff.
So, we are excited about "The Batman."
So...
(audience cheering)
We're excited.
So what can you tell us about it?
You play Penguin.
- I play, yeah.
I play Oz,
who's kind of,
hasn't embodied the penguin yet,
but is known as The Penguin
basically because he has a bit
of an awkward gait,
and yeah.
It was ama...
Oh yeah, there is it.
A really extraordinary makeup
artist called Mike Marino,
kind of designed the character.
I will say I can...
- Wait, wait, what?
Wait, that's not you though.
- Yeah.
- Wait, what?
(audience laughing)
I didn't see that picture.
Oh, my God.
- [Colin] You didn't, really?
- [Kelly] I just heard
that you were Penguin.
What the hell?
- [Colin] Oh, you haven't seen that?
- [Kelly] That person
deserves to win awards.
- [Colin] Oh no, no, no, he should.
Yeah, yeah.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] That's you?
- No, it's amazing.
It's amazing what he was, and
he designed the whole thing.
- I couldn't download
the photo last night,
and I kept telling her, I was like,
I never saw him as Penguin.
- It's amazing.
- Oh my gosh.
- The first time I saw the makeup was,
they had done a, he had done a mold of
my face and I saw it on a screen.
Matt Reeves' screen the director,
the writer-director of The Batman.
He said do you wanna see
what Mike Marino's done?
What he thinks Oz is gonna look like?
And I said, yeah.
And he showed me the screen.
I just, I didn't know it
was going in that direction.
And I went, holy smoke.
And I'd never done
anything like that before.
And I can't claim...
- What kind of time did
it take to look like that?
- Four hours, four hours.
(gasps) I complain about...
At the start four hours
and then they got it down
to two and it was fine.
'Cause I knew the reward was immense.
And it was...
- You're a different human.
- It was extraordinary, Kelly.
It was so liberating.
- Did you ever go out in that?
- No, we did...
- I would've gone out in that.
- We did a test.
- And then talk (beep)
about Colin Ferrell.
(laughs)
- I would have been you.
- See how people really feel.
Until you find out they're like, sorry,
never heard of him.
Oh, checked ego.
(audience clapping)
- That would have been
what I would have done.
- That experiment backfired.
- It was amazing.
- That's crazy.
Yeah, so I can,
I've never been able
to take less ownership
over a performance in my life.
- Yeah, it's like so physically different.
- It's like, I don't know if
it's like 50-50, 49-51, 60-40.
I'm not sure.
- Oh my gosh.
But Mike Marino and myself and
then Matt of course wrote it.
You know, it's,
you didn't have to do much.
- So intense.
It was like an alchemy, yeah.
When it went on the first time
and just you're hidden and you
just have absolute freedom.
- Oh my God, I will never
complain about spanks again.
(laughs)
- Having it on four hours, so it's a lot.